I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name kill
every Targaryen I get my hands on
is an enemy start is it bring me it's
can't we take what is ours
there are guards
you don't think I'd let you marry that
beast eale I now proclaim Cersei of the
House Lannister
protector of the Seven Kingdoms
Lannister Targaryen Baratheon stark
Tyrell
respects Gnomeo this one's on top and
that one's on and on and on
spend
crushing those on the ground
[Music]
the same thing is coming for all of us
there's only one war that
[Music]
the griddle
and it is here
[Music]
congratulations for revealing the
premiere date for season seven I can
personally assure you it will be worth
the wait
what's up everybody we got to talk about
this game of thrones premiere date
there's all kinds of stuff happening
this week there's a new round of the
game of Thrones giveaway I'm giving away
the enhanced editions of the books all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so if you never thought that you would
sit around watching a block of ice melt
on the internet you just did it and even
though the stream broke a couple times
they actually surprise surprise posted a
trailer at the end of it instead of just
announcing the premiere date so they
went way above and beyond and the really
cool thing about this is that it
actually teases a lot of Dragonstone
stuff so they make these dragons look
like dragon glass it's almost like a
dragon glass version of a teaser trailer
it opens with Daenerys acknowledging the
Mad King I know what he was I'm not
going to become him because she's trying
to take the Iron Throne and become the
new ruler of Westeros so a lot of people
are worried that she's just gonna do the
exact same thing how is she going to be
different from her father even Dan and
Dave teased that the way they have her
written is that she has a little bit of
that fire in her so there is a little
bit of the Mad King in her even though
if you believe that she's going to rise
to be one of the main antagonists of the
series she will ultimately not be the
big bad should just be the big bad for a
couple different storylines like Circe's
the thing I love about the way they
morph this too is that it morphs for the
different house sigils you go to the
dialogue of Robert Baratheon I'll kill
every Targaryen I get my hands on the
progression here is obviously based on
the narration but it also tells the
story of what's happened on the show so
far so you see the lion attacking the
stag the story of how they killed Robert
Baratheon in sort of took power for
House Lannister even though technically
Cersei is still a Baratheon it's just
like the saddle Ament is the slow fault
of the House of Baratheon
even though Gendry is still around you
get the Joffrey hat tip how he had Ned
Stark beheaded back in season one then
Balon Greyjoy as he rises up the War of
the five kings get started
the really gruesome Roose Bolton red
wedding quote the Lannisters send their
regards is the lion starts to eat this
dragonglass dire wolf the vines from the
sigil of house Tyrell wrapping around
the lion's paw you didn't think I'd
actually let you marry that person
talking about the Queen of thorns during
season 4 engineering the perp
wedding in concert with a couple of
other people including Littlefinger then
the effortless flow into this giant wild
fire explosion consuming the Tyrell
sigil from the season six finale I now
proclaim Cersei Queen of the Seven
Kingdoms and then as it sort of morphs
into the Dragon wrapping around all of
the other sigils that really cool
Daenerys quote where she talks about how
all the Great Houses fight and war with
each other ones on top than the others
on top I'm going to break that wheel
then as this dragonglass wheel is broken
the Jon Snow quote the same thing is
coming for all of us and then morphs
into that children of the forest pattern
that the knight King keeps drawing with
bodies such a great way to end the
teaser - as it pans out and morphs into
the Knights Kings blue eye so the really
important stuff
the date is 716 meaning the 16th of July
so what's gonna happen is is this is
basically falling after they finished
the John Oliver season after most of
HBO's other series are done so Game of
Thrones will rule the entire summer in
seriously in the build-up to that first
episode dropping they're gonna be
promoting it so much it'll just take
over everything else even when it's not
on the air so the added bonus of having
to wait this extra time for it to get
here is that you have to wait less time
for season 8 to start because it sounds
like because of the way they're filming
and winter coming that they'll start
production in September meaning that the
schedule next year will be almost the
exact same as it was this year so
instead of waiting a year and I have to
get new Game of Thrones you'll be
waiting like eight months so it'll be
way less of a bummer waiting for that
final season and they even said that
there might be some extra episodes that
they'll tack on they're still
determining the final episode count for
season 8 but touching base with all the
characters at the beginning of season 7
so we have Daenerys that is sailing for
Dorne
she'll Mass her fleet there she has the
Tyrells basically it's the Targaryen
restoration so it's the forces of Dorne
some of the other smaller houses of
Westeros but mostly it's the Tyrells in
the Greyjoy fleet so they're just like a
couple main forces even though I
wouldn't be surprised if you see a lot
of other banners in there like Jon Snow
when he was preparing for the Battle of
the bastards they were trying to get
help from all the lesser houses up in
the north so you saw a lot of different
banners fighting for
side-biting for the Bolton's it'll be
the same thing for Daenerys in the
forces of the crown as they face off
against each other and then while that's
all going on and Dorne you have the
stuff that's going on over at the
Citadel with Samuel at the brand-new
Meister character that I explained I'll
link that video at the end of this
because it's gonna be really exciting
most of the technical information that
we need to learn will come from that
storyline then you have Cersei in the
crown trying to cement her hold on the
people it sounds like she's gonna be
vicious so there'll be some rebellion
that she'll have to put down just being
more like the Mad King the way that
Daenerys says that she's not going to be
like that so if you really like watching
Cersei be cruel to people it is gonna be
so much fun for you during season seven
and then you have arya up in the river
lance still it'll be interesting to see
how long she sticks around there but she
just killed Walder Frey so they'll deal
with the aftermath of that then you have
the Brotherhood that's slowly heading
north with the Hound they'll eventually
reach the north Winterfell and you have
all the stuff as they prepare for the
war for the dawn so Jon Snow is mostly
focusing on the ultimate threat but
Sansa will probably get involved with
the more practical day-to-day stuff
because even though there's this big
threat most of the people in the kingdom
have no idea what's going on with the
White Walkers and probably would not
believe you if you told them so a big
part of season seven one of the big
threads is in proving to everyone else
that there is a threat that they need to
face because beyond the people that Jon
Snow has been fighting with for the last
season or so there aren't a whole lot of
people that have actually seen a white
Walker so most of the Lords of the north
and all their people are really just
concerned with their own business right
now like the Bolton's were terrible they
wanted a stark in Winterfell they got
that so unless you can prove to them
there's some greater threat then they're
just gonna go back to their lives and
you'll lose your army but they did this
really interesting thing tying plot
threads together at the end of season
six
you know we're bi you have the Ravens of
the Citadel and like the smoke rising
out here showing that winter had begun
the maesters disseminate information so
I'll be interested to see how they touch
on Samwell storyline as they sort of
catch all the other characters around
Westeros up on what's going on so Jon
Snow has no idea what's going on with
Daenerys his fleet way down south but
someone will eventually have to send him
a raven so you'll see him reading a
that like oh this Targaryen threat we
should probably do something about this
but that sounds more like Littlefinger
sonses stuff they seem like more
big-picture politicking people Jon
Snow's eyes are mostly turned towards
the wall in north of the wall and then
you have brands stark that's north of
the wall - I was originally gonna do a
video about him till they drop this but
the thing that Isaac hem said right was
saying is is they shot his scenes really
early on so there's not going to be a
ton of brand but it'll mostly take place
at the wall and if they're gonna end in
some big climactic moment that'll make
you crazy for season 8 episode 1 it'll
be the night king arriving at the wall
with his army they might actually push
him crossing through the wall to the
beginning of season 8 but anything could
happen they're gonna be seven episodes
in season seven so there will be zero
filler and there's also reports that
each of the episodes will be an extra 20
minutes long so imagine if a normal
episode is around 52 to 53 minutes long
just imagine it almost being 50% longer
for each of the seven episodes and
they're all not exactly the same length
some episodes are always a little bit
longer than others especially the big
action set pieces like battle of the
bastards but just expect more in that
vein so if you want more Game of Thrones
you will totally be getting it even
though it seems like we're getting fewer
episodes there's still the same amount
of content but let me know what you guys
are most hype about and if there's any
bonus videos you guys want me to do
before Sunday just let me know there's
gonna be a big game of Thrones panel at
South by Southwest they might show off
some more footage because they drop this
teaser it seems like they're ramping up
to more big stuff so there'll be more
trailers coming in the next couple
months but what's gonna happen later is
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
drop so I'll try to get through it as
fast as possible what you wait for that
click here to learn all about that brand
new character they're bringing on in
season 7 and you can click here for the
other teasers that they just drop thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you